[موسيقى]
في صور المشاهير والاقطاتهم المصوره يظهر
في الخلفيه اشخاص بمواصفات امنيه خاصه
يراقبون الجميع باحترافيه ويحرصون على
انفاذ الامن انهم الحراس الشخصيون لهؤلاء
الاشخاص وهم جزء من منظومه الحمايه
الامنيه الخاصه التي تعنى بالمنشات
المختلفه كالمطارات والمتاجر والمنازل
والمتاحف والمعارض والمؤتمرات وغيرها فكيف
حدث ذلك قبل الميلاد بنحو 1300 عام خصص
الفراعنه جنودا لحمايتهم وعائلاتهم كجنود
المتجر الذين استخدمهم رمسيس الثاني دون
ان يمنحهم اي اجر في اليونان القديمه
اختار الاسكندر الاكبر افضل جنوده لحمايته
الشخصيه وسماهم السماتو فايليكس كذلك عرفت
وحده الحرس الامبراطوري عند الرومان التي
تحولت لاحقا
جمعيه الاباطره كانت للحضارات القديمه
عموما انظمه حمايه بعضها اعتبر رمزا
لقوتها كمحاربين نبلاء اليابان الساموراي
الذين امتلكوا قوى النافذه مع مرور الوقت
وكذلك القوات المحرمه بالصين التي حمت
اسره تانج كما عرفت نماذج حراسه النسائيه
بالهند القديمه حيث استقطبت المحاربات من
اسيا الوسطى في العصور المظلمه مع انتشار
الحروب في اوروبا الغربيه
ظهر ما يسمى الجنود الماجورين وكان يدفع
لهم لشن الحرب او لدرئها حيث تعاقدت معهم
بلدات او شخصيات اعتباريه وربما كانت هذه
بمثابه بدايه الامن الخاص في القرن الثامن
عشر حيث وجدت شركات للامن الخاص بشكل رسمي
في بريطانيا استخدمها اصحاب المصانع
البريطانيه لكبح الاضرابات العماليه كما
مولت الحكومه
لغايه تعقب المجرمين تبع ذلك تاسيس شركه
بينكرتون كاول شركه امنيه خاصه في امريكا
عام
1850 بغرض توفير حراس لشركات السكك
الحديديه والقطاع الخاص حتى مطلع القرن
العشرين لعب الحرس الشخصي للحكام ادوارا
مهمه فنجح حرس نابليون في حمايته من تفجير
عبوات ناسفه ونجت الملكه فيكتوريا من
محاولات اغتيال عديده كما تخطى الرئيس
الفرنسي تشارل دي غول كما ان عده لكن
وحدات الحمايات العسكريه تحولت لاحقا
لرموز تراثيه واصبحت تستخدم في
الاستعراضات والمناسبات الوطنيه كحرس
الملكه الذي اصبح رمزا سياحيا جاذبا بلندن
في عشرينيات القرن العشرين تراجع التوظيف
الامني الخاص بسبب الكساد وتبعات الحروب
لكنه اندعش بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وتوسعت خدماته بشكل كبير لتشمل توفير
الحمايات للاثرياء والمشاهير وغزا جميع
القطاعات واصبحت شركات الامن تقدم خدمات
اكثر احترافيه كالاستشارات الامنيه
والتدريب والدعم التشغيلي
والاستخباراتي واداره المخاطر وانفاذ
القانون بمجال الارهاب والمخدرات والجريمه
المنظمه وحمايه الموارد الطبيعيه والنقل
الامن للسجناء وخدمات اخرى بعضها كان
مثارا للاستهجان ففي عام 2003 تصدرت شركه
نورس بريدج عناوين الصحف عندما عرض
التحرير الرئيس الليبيري المحاصر انذاك
تشارلز تيلر مقابل اربعه ملايين دولار
خلال السنوات الاخيره ارتفع الطلب على
الامنيه ففي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بلغ حجم سوق خدمات الامن ما يقرب من 52
مليار دولار في عام 2022 كما قدر عدد حراس
الامن في العقود الخارجيه وحدها بنحو 830
الفا اليوم يخضع الحارس الشخصي لتدريبات
للتعامل مع الطوارئ والاسعافات الاوليه
وتحليل البيانات واستخدام تكنولوجيا
الذكاء الاصطناعي كما يتقاضى اجرا يتراوح
بين 20 و 100 دولار في الساعه ويزيد على
ذلك للحراس المسلحين والعسكريين
المتقاعدين بعد ان كانت خدماته مجانيه في
العصر الفرعوني
[موسيقى]